[Música]
Muito boa noite a todos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live.
Boa noite, Alice Bog, Cleidvan, Eliseu
e quem mais tiver assistindo ao vivo.
Muito bem, vamos às perguntas.
Pessoal, quem tiver acompanhando do
celular, me diga como é que tá essa nova
apresentação
em retrato, tá bom? Quero saber como é
que vocês estão tendo essa experiência
com acompanhamento pelo celular.
Bem, vamos lá. Doutor, em relação ao seu
vídeo recente sobre uso de doses maiores
de vitamina C para modular o cortisol,
por quanto tempo seria o uso das doses
mais altas? O excesso de vitamina C
eliminado na urina poderia aumentar o
risco de formação de cálculos urinários?
É uma pergunta bem relevante. Sim.
O período vai ser muito variável
dependendo da situação da pessoa, né?
Pode ser três meses, pode ser 6 meses,
pode ser um ano. E existe sim esse risco
de pessoas que estão desidratadas, que
não bebem água ou que tem dieta ruim, da
vitamina C em excesso provocar mais
eliminação de oxilato na urina.
Teve um estudo publicado recentemente
com mulheres que tinham cortisol elevado
e utilizaram 1 g de vitamina C diários
durante 2 meses e sim houve uma redução
significativa dos níveis de cortisol.
Então a gente pode ter que usar 2, 3, 4,
5, 6 meses até um ano. Vai depender
muito do grau da intensidade dessa
alteração do cortisol.
Então, que em relação ao risco de
cálculos renais, esse questionamento tá
bem correto. Se você fizer um consumo de
vitamina C por muito tempo tiver
desidratado,
pode se informar cálculos renais pela
deposição de oxalato.
Então é muito importante estar tomando 2
a 3 L de água por dia, monitorar a
função renal e realmente
diminuir a dose da vitamina C quando for
pertinente.
A próxima. A quantidade de betaglucana
disponível
na aveia é suficiente para torná-la um
alimento saudável?
A veia é um alimento complexo, tá? Ele
tem coisas boas na veia e coisas ruins.
Então a gente tem que analisar dessa
forma. A aveia tem ótimos nutrientes,
mas também tem antinutrientes.
Betaglucana presente na aveia oferece
benefícios documentados para quem não
tem intolerância aos antinutrientes.
3 g de aveia reduzem significativamente
na maioria dos pacientes a resposta
glicêmica pósprandial, ou seja, vai
subir menos o açúcar do sangue após
alimentação
e vai ajudar a regular os níveis de
colesterol LDL, promover saciedade,
melhorar a microbiota intestinal. O teor
de betaglucana na veia varia entre 2 a
7%.
Isso foi aferido por agências como FDA e
a FSA.
Tem que lembrar que a veia tem glúten e
tem avenina e tem o glúten também do
trigo. Então tem muitas pessoas que
podem ter acessibilidade à aveia.
Então vai ter gente que vai ter
inflamação intestinal comendo aveia.
Existem também alternativas. Você pode
estar ingerindo essa betaglucana
retirada de fungo, você pode estar
ingerindo essa betaglocana retirada de
cevada sem glúten, você pode estar
ingerindo também da levedura de cerveja.
Então a aveia não é a única fonte
betagrucana, ok? Então, se você tiver
intolerância aveia, eu particularmente
eu não me dou bem com aveia, gosto muito
do sabor, mas me solta tremendamente o
intestino. Nesse caso, eu sugiro que
faça uso de outras fontes betaglucana.
Tenho 59 anos. O betacitosterol pode ser
utilizado de forma contínua em doses
menores, como prevenção de HPB, 250 mg,
por exemplo.
Pode, não é obrigado a tomar dose de
alta, não, tá?
Como é que o betacistosterol, citosterol
age, né? Ele vai inibir a 5 alfa
redutase,
bloquear a conversão de testosterona e
de hidrotestos.
E ele tem um efeito também direto na
parede da bexiga, relaxando a parede da
bexiga.
Então não há nenhum problema de fazer
essa dose que você tá sugerindo, 250 mg.
Ele é muito bem tolerado
e nunca vi problemas de efeitos
colaterais com esse precipio ativo. Não
tem que lembrar que também além do
betacitosterol procurar manter os seus
zinc em níveis adequados.
Lembrar do licopeno que é anticâncer
para próstata, né?
que vem do tomate, é interessante
ômega-3,
retirar os alimentos inflamatórios da
alimentação, além de fazer
acompanhamento periódico com PSA,
ultrassom
e se for o toque até se for caso até o
toque, né?
Rotina diária, acorda 5 horas da manhã,
vou paraa grama. Vou pra grama. Ah, deve
ser para o pé na grama, né? Pé no chão,
faço alongamento. Às 6 horas bebo 600 ml
de água com sal rosa.
Às 6:30 tomo creatina, glutamina, meio
limão.
30 gotas de própolis, astofalipoico, às
7 horas, café da manhã, sempre com
proteínas e gorduras. Não como
carboidrato
a 76 curcuminacisteína
corebiome
day multivitamínico,
trem de musculação, jantar
cocuminicorbiome
paá. Você acha que estou certo? Devo
fazer alguma mudança?
Eu vou falar aqui em termos gerais, tá?
Não é o objetivo dessa live de nenhuma
outra live fazer consultas informais
aqui, tá bom? Mas vou falar em termos
gerais que de maneira que possa ser
aproveitado pelo maior número de pessoas
do grupo.
Bem, a estrutura já tá boa, tá
implementando protocolos bem
interessantes, né? O contato com a
grama, né? o grounding, a hidratação, o
uso do sal rosa, o alfa lipoico, a
corcumina,
o corebiô que ajuda a modular a flora,
né, intestinal,
o timing está colocando a creatina em
glutamina, tá correto? A curcomina após
almoço é bom porque ingerida junto com a
gordura vai ajudar
a absorver.
Minha sugestão principal seria realizar
sua estratégia pós- treino entre as 16
horas
e às 18 horas
tem um gap aí de recuperação.
Então você poderia se beneficiar de uma
refeição pós- treino contendo proteína
com carboidrato complexo.
Poderia ser banana com amendoim, por
exemplo, ou aquele creme de amendoim sem
açúcar, ou batata doce com ovo, ou
batata doce com frango. Isso poderia
melhorar a cites proteica e recuperação
e otimizar os níveis de cortisol.
E a segunda observação, se você ficar
sem carboidratos no café, não seria
prejudicial?
Seu objetivo é queimar gordura.
Mas precisa observar sua energia ao
longo do treino. Se você tiver queda
desempenho durante o treino, pode
colocar carboidratos complexos no
pré-treino.
O protocolo de magnésio noturno tá bom
para recuperação e sono.
E parabéns aí pela sua disciplina e
marque uma consulta com o médico da
linha funcional para tá acompanhando
seus exames, tá bom?
Vocês
estão me ouvindo bem, né? Porque eu tô
usando esse fone da Apple aqui.
Até agora eu não tô tendo nenhum
comentário aqui de que ninguém tá me
ouvindo bem. Não.
Temos acesso à manteiga por quilo.
No processo banho maria fiz a manteiga
Gui pergunta: "No mercado hoje é
possível eles criarem algo tão idêntico
com a manteiga de vaca? Eu não sei se eu
entendi a sua pergunta. Você começou
falando de manteiga Gui e depois tu tá
falando de uns alguma coisa que é
idêntica a manteiga de vaca. Não sei se
eu entendi a pergunta. Maria Helena.
Tá. Se você tá perguntando sobre essa
engenharia de alimentos e tem uma
startup chamada Kubic Foods.
Eles estão desenvolvendo alternativas
sintéticas à base de óleos vegetais.
para imitar a manteiga,
mas eu não recomendaria usar isso aí.
Toda vez que invento de usar óleo
vegetal para imitar
a manteiga, não dá muito certo no final.
Eu
acho que é muito melhor você continuar
seu protocolo, fazer sua manteiga em
casa
ou ainda se você quiser comprar manteiga
G pronta também pode ser
que seria muito melhor com que a
alternativa sintética como margarina ou
esse que eu acabei de falar aí.
E a grande vantagem da matega GU que
você elimina toda a proteína, né, da
gordura. da manteiga e elimina também a
lactose.
Essa clarificação vai eliminar tanto a
proteína caseína quanto a lactose.
É uma fonte de gordura limpa para você.
Eu usava melatonina em 10 mg há anos.
Sop?
Eh, contei a você sobre dor de cabeça
faz uns 3 meses e você orientou a passar
para 20 mg.
Tá, mas essa dose de melonina alta é
para ação antioxidante, mas para câncer,
tá?
Eu
não tô lembrado dessa orientação não.
Você pode usar melatonina 20 mg por um
tempo, mas eu não recomendo ficar
tomando direto, tá?
Mas tá tomando por causa de dor de
cabeça a melatonina. Eu não me lembro de
ter orientado você tomar melatonina para
dor de cabeça. Foi numa live isso ou foi
em consulta? Você tá ao vivo, Maria
Helena? Tá sim. Você tá me ouvindo? Pode
me dizer se foi em consulta ou foi em
alguma live?
Hum. Sim. O quê? Você colocou sim, mas
não entendi. Sim. O quê?
Tá, vamos continuar aqui. Depois você
fala, né?
Boa noite. A Nest comprou a pura vida.
Na opinião, isso afeta a qualidade dos
produtos e qual espirulina você indica?
Então, não é de hoje isso aí, tá? Tem
uns dois anos que a Nestr comprou a pura
Vida.
Não é novidade disso não,
ó. Foi em maio de 2022, já tem mais de 2
anos, na verdade.
E até onde a gente sabe, a Nestle
manteve a operação independente dessa
marca.
E muita gente criticou o Flávio Passos
na época quando ele fez a venda junto
com os sócios dele e agora ele tá com
essa história da puríssima aí, né?
Bem, oficialmente os dados mostram que a
pura vida continua com seus padrões de
produção de alimentos orgânicos naturais
e clean label.
Até agora eu não recebi nenhuma denúncia
que justificasse de ficar desconfiado.
Mas existe um histórico muito antigo da
Nestle não ser uma empresa assim
exatamente friendly aí de coisas
naturais e orgânicas, tá?
Então a gente tem que ficar com o pé
atrás mesmo.
Então, a princípio, não acho que você
deve mudar de marca, não, tá?
A não ser que a gente tenha uma denúncia
aí consistente de que eles estão
esculhambando.
Qualquer dúvida você pode pedir também
um laudo de análise contaminação para
eles.
Quando eu tomei pela primeira vez o
combo da energia, você tinha ali
carnetina 2 g, 300 mg de cozima Q10 PQQ,
senti muita disposição. Da segunda vez
em diante eu não senti a mesma
disposição. Devo aumentar a dose de com
enzima Q10. Muito obrigado.
Você pode aumentar sim, sem problema
nenhum. É muito segura a coisa Q10, tá?
e pode ter sido uma tolerância
adaptativa
ao suplemento.
Mas eh como tem estudo de coes maquiais
com gramas, né, para insuficia renal, a
coisa maquia é muito segura, você pode
aumentar tranquilamente
e você pode também aumentar a dose do PQ
e da Colle Carnitina. Eu tenho passado
mais em consultório 3 g, tá?
Do que dois
para tomar de manhã.
Agora, se você for fazer os sem
acompanhamento médico, faça em ciclos,
tá? Use eh calor desses ativos
separadamente por 2 3 meses, descanse o
mês e reinicie.
E aí você pode também otimizar a
absorção comendo um alimento gorduroso
junto, já que esses ativos são
liposolúveis.
Outra coisa pode estar fazendo é
associar o magnésio
e revisitar sua alimentação para ver se
não tem algo inflamatório, tá? como
leite, derivados, glúten, e podem estar
piorando o efeito dos suplementos.
Para cálculos na vesícula, vi que é bom
chá da folha de alcachofra.
Poderia ser tomado em cápsulas também.
Nesse caso, em qual concentração? A
cachorfro impede a formação de novos
cálculos ou dissolóvios que já tem?
Bem, não é que é o cachofra vai
dissolver pedra do na vesícula, não. O
cachofre é muito bom como colerético
para ajudar a ao rim, eliminar, né, os o
suco biliar na vesícula e também no
intestino.
O ideal do cachofre é usar em forma de
chá ou tintura,
porque assim tem maior controle sobre
concentração e absorção dos princípios
ativos, que é a sinarina, né, e os
flavonoides.
Se optar pelas cápsulas, as
concentrações que você pode utilizar
entre 250 a 400 mg, uma, duas cápsulas
duas vezes ou três vezes ao dia.
E tem estudos que sugerem que o tempo de
6 a 12 semanas é o tempo necessário para
ter resultados mais consistentes.
E como eu disse, ao cachorro não vai
dissolver cálculos, tá? Ela vai ajudar,
ela é colerética, aumenta a secreção
biliar, pode ajudar a expulsar aí areia,
mas tirar a pedra é bem difícil de
acontecer.
Existe até o risco, se tiver uma pedra
grande, desse aumento de fluxo de bil
causar obstrução do cutubiliar, tá?
Então tem que ficar atento, tem que ter
um acompanhamento médico. Aí
o que você pode tentar para dissolver a
a pedra da vesícula é utilizar o údica,
né, que é o ácido uso deoxicólico,
ou o túdica, que é o tauro úso
deoxicólico, tá? Esse daí pode te ajudar
um ano de uso aí a dissolver pedra na
vesícula, mas não
eh o cachofro não vai ter esse efeito
não.
Para pernas extremamente inchadas e
doloridas feito exame,
foi descartado a a possibilidade de nova
trombose bilateral. Qual o melhor
procedimento para quem tem neoplazia
renal e hipertensão, considerando um
paciente de 90 anos? Massagem de
exercício chá de quçatóico, calendola
não tem resolvido.
Bem, é um paciente, mulher, né? É isso.
90 anos, neoplasia renal, pressão alta.
Bem, com esse histórico aí, o edema,
obviamente deve ser por conta de renal.
precisa revisar com muito critério
medicação antihipertensível que ela tá
tomando.
Bloqueadores de canal de cálcio, por
exemplo, como é o caso na angilodipino e
nefidipino,
podem causar edema de membros
inferiores.
Tenho que avaliar a função renal vendo
creatinina, vendo filturação glomerular,
ureia, entender exatamente o grau de
comprometimento renal, verificar
rigorosamente a ingestão de sódio, tanto
de líquido que tá tomando.
Se tiver essência renal crônica, tem que
reduzir o líquido e o sal.
Meia de compressão média nas pernas pode
ajudar quando esver bem ajustado
para reduzir o edema. Elevação das
pernas acima do nível do coração também
pode ajudar.
Dependendo se não tiver
contraindicações, pode utilizar um
diurético em dose baixa,
um rigoroso monitoramento, né, para ver
se não vai ter algum tipo de
desequilíbrio eletrolítico.
Poderia tá dando uns chás assim
diuréticos também, chá de cavalinha, por
exemplo,
investigar informação sistêmica
relacionada ao câncer de de rim. Não sei
que tipo de tratamento fez para esse
câncer de rim, não sei se é inop, pode
ser um câncer inope, né, inoperável.
Ã, talvez fazer uso aí de um
tratamento alternativo para esse câncer
aí de rim, né? Você pode pensar, por
exemplo, em usar
o bisco álbum.
Seria interessante.
Bem, eu acho que é isso, né? Se você
tiver ao vivo, Ana Lú, vocês podem
discutir um pouco mais, tá?
Doutor, no seu último vídeo sobre
vitamina C,
menciona sobre ajuda no tratamento de
cortisol alto. Posso considerar a mesma
dose, 2 g em dois em quatro tomadas para
ajuda do tratamento de cortisol baixo?
Pode sim, a vitamina C pode ajudar na
situação de cortisol baixo, porque eh se
o cortisol hoje tá baixo, que vi um dia
esteve alto, né? Então, eh, a vitamina C
é muito utilizada pelas adrenais para
produzir os hormônios, né, da
suprarrenal.
Mas além da vitamina C, teria que
investigar porque que o cicócio está
baixo, né?
Teria que pensar em adaptógenos aí para
melhorar a situação, tomar rodola rosa,
licorice,
a chaganda.
Tem vários adaptóos que a gente pode
estar pensando.
Pode ser necessário repor com sal
integral, né? É bem comum as pessoas que
têm cortisol baixo ter pressão
baixa e e tonturas, né? E aí com sódio
de origem aí natural, um sal integral
junto com água, vai ajudar
a controlar essa pressão. também repor
potássio e magnésio for necessário,
que tem casos que pode ser necessário
entrar com hidrocortis na base
e outras vitaminas do complexo B, eh,
doses altas de vitamina B5 são bem
importantes aí para fadiga de origem
adrenal,
certo?
Mas sim, pode usar vitamina C nessa
dosagem, sim, vai ajudar, não é? única
coisa, mas vai ajudar.
Boa noite, doutor.
Alguns suplementos, como Boraprin, por
exemplo, coloca em sua fórmula, como
antioxidantes para substâncias a
vitamina E sintética, normalmente 5 a 10
mg por dose. Essa quantidade pode ser
prejudicial para saúde e suplemento de
uso contínuo.
Então, nesse caso, é um pouco diferente,
tá? A vitamina E tá ali para evitar do
produto ser oxidado. Eh, então ela não é
ali a estrela principal, né? É um
aditivo para evitar a deterioração do
produto. Nesse caso, não tem tanto
problema de tá sendo uma vitamina E
sintética,
porque, né, ela tá ali para evitar a
oxidação do produto principal.
Porém, se você puder arrumar um produto
que não tenha vitamina E sintética, é
melhor, tá?
Se você puder achar um que tem o a famal
natural do afocoferol é melhor.
Se você puder fazer essa
pesquisa por um produto que tenha o de
alfa tocoferol, seria melhor.
Mas a princípio a dose não tá alta e é
uma dose justamente para evitar a
oxidação do produto principal e não para
repor vitamina E.
Eh, eu não tenho essa
explicar uma coisa para vocês, pessoal.
A as lives é para justamente a gente
responder as dúvidas, tá? O grupo de
WhatsApp é muito mais para vocês do que
para mim. Eu vou lá, coloco as mensagens
com
as datas das lives, os links das lives
das perguntas, mas a o meu proposta ali
não é ficar o tempo todo no grupo
olhando as mensagens de vocês, tá?
O que acha das afirmações do doutor?
Podem ter alguma base de realidade que o
doutor está falando? Gente, deixa sempre
as perguntas completas, tá? Não tentam
fazer essa
conexão com o que vocês mandaram no
WhatsApp, porque realmente eu não vejo a
maior parte das mensagens ali, tá?
A médica está divulgando esse trabalho
dele. Dele? Quem? Eu não sei do que você
tá falando. Desculpa. D Renato.
Se você tiver ao vivo, a gente pode
estar vendo isso hoje. Como não tem
muita pergunta, tá? Eu vou responder as
dúvidas ao vivo também, tá bom? Então,
se você tiver acompanhando ao vivo,
Antônio Renato, vamos conversar sobre
isso, porque eu não vi a mensagem do
grupo, tá?
Para toquinárias ser eficaz no combate à
progressão da aterosclerose, a dose deve
ser 10.000
fu e a dose mais baixa 3600 fu é eficaz?
Sim. Você pegou os dados corretos, tá?
Um grande estudo clínico com mais de
1000 pacientes demonstrou que a
natoquinase em dose de 10.800 FU por
dia, durante 1 ano reduziu placa
arterial carotida em 36%.
Enquanto que a dose de 3600 fuamente
ineficaz.
Interessante que o efeito, né, da
natoquinase foi mais ainda pronunciado
em pessoas sedentárias,
obesas, fumantes e consumidoras de
álcool.
Então, a adição de vitamina K2 e
aspirina potencializou ainda mais os
resultados.
Então, use a dose 10.000 Fu, tá?
usa essa dose que é é mais eficiente,
bem mais eficiente,
obviamente associado a mudança estilo de
vida, né?
Exercício regular, alimentação
antiinflamatória, eliminação dos
alimentos inflamatórios.
Beleza?
Descobri que na calistenia o atleta
passa por quatro níveis: iniciante,
intermediário, avançado e elite.
No nível iniciante há ganho de força,
mas não há ganho de massa muscular. A
partir do nível intermediário, a ganho
de massa muscular e o atleta pode ganhar
a mesma massa muscular que ganharia na
musculação natural sem anabolizantes.
A explicação é que na musculação você
ganha massa muscular através da
contração excêntrica,
enquanto que na calistenia você ganha
massa muscular através do movimento
isométrico.
Isso significa que a partir do nível
intermediário da calistenia
a ganho de testosterona, assim como na
musculação,
tem sim, tem ganho de testosterona sim,
tá?
Na verdade, o corpo ele não vai
distinguir se você tá levantando peso
eh na máquina, peso livre ou é o próprio
peso do corpo, tá? Isso não, o corpo não
quer saber quanto que tem o estímulo
muscular
e você pode ter sim um ganho de massa
muscular no nível iniciante, tá? Não
precisa ser necessariamente só no
intermediário, não.
Vai ter um ganho mais expressivo, mas
não quer dizer que no nível iniciante
você não vai ganhar massa muscular.
E outra coisa, tanto na musculação
quanto na calistenia, você trabalha com
as três fases da contração muscular,
concêntrica, excêntrica e isométrica. Na
calistenia não tem só isométrico, tá?
Tem movimentos dinâmicos completos. O
que realmente difere é a progressão de
sobrecarga e a especificidade do
movimento, não o tipo de contração.
Então, grande massa muscular
vai causar
aumento de testosterona independente do
tipo de estímulo que você proporcionar,
sendo exercício de força, né, ou de
resistência.
Então isso não faz diferença se vai ser
calistenia ou se vai ser musculação,
tá? O que vai determinar mais é a
frequência do treino e o descanso, né?
se se você tem o descanso adequado do
treino,
porque se você fizer um treino
exagerado, entrar em overtrain, você vai
perder massa muscular em vez de ganhar.
Então, por isso que é importante você
ter o descanso adequado e o treino
também com o estímulo adequado,
tá? Então, não é o ganho de massa
exatamente o que faz ganhar
testosterona,
tá? é o treino em si de força que
estimula a produção de testosterona.
E isso vai independer do tipo de
estímulo que você fizer, contando que
seja um estímulo de força, eh, ou que
chama de resistência, que é o termo
técnico, tá? Quando a gente fala
resistência, não é resistência no
sentido de ter resistência à bicicleta,
eh, é o termo técnico para exercício de
força, tá?
Você
recomenda o uso do suplemento Relora?
Sim, eu gosto desse suplemento. Até
quanto tempo antes da musculação?
Não tem uma recomendação do reló
especificamente para musculação, não. É,
geralmente é tomada à noite esse
suplemento para ajudar no sono, tá? A
partir de quanto tempo antes da
musculação? Não tem esse problema. Você
pode tomar antes ou depois. Geralmente é
a noite que se toma, tá? depois da
musculação.
Não tem esse intervalo específico não,
tá? Eh, não conheço no estudo falando de
timing do reló que tem que ser X minutos
antes ou depois, mas como eu falei, a
maioria das pessoas tomam na hora de
deitar.
Se você tá tomando reló, não só para
melhorar o sono, mas também para acalmar
o cérebro, você pode tomar, por exemplo,
250 mg de manhã e 250 mg antes de deitar
e vai ajudar você a recuperar os
treinos.
A consistência diária é que o ponto
chave não timing, tá? em relação ao
horário do treino ou da tomada,
tá bom?
Ã,
manter o amalguma do dente, obtoração
intoxica a pessoa com mercúrio, mas se a
pessoa tomar suplemento antioxidante,
ela elimina esse mercúrio? Não depende,
vai depender muito do
organismo da pessoa e a taxa de detox
desse organismo. Se a pessoa tiver um
detox bom, ela pode até eliminar esse
mercúrio todo. Se ela tiver um detox
ruim, ela não vai conseguir eliminar.
E se tomar um suplemento antioxidante,
com certeza vai ajudar, mas não é
garantia que vai eliminar o mercúrio,
não.
Isso seria uma solução permanente de
modo que o amálgama contamina com
mergulho todo dia. É a questão quando
você mastiga, né, ou quando você range
os dentes, o mercúrio do amalgam pode
sair e pode ter essa contaminação, uma
pequena quantidade todo dia.
E a pessoa através de suplemento expulsa
esse mercúrio todo dia. Sim. O organismo
tá sempre expulsando o mercúrio do
organismo, mas aí o ponto é que não dá
para garantir que essa expulsão é
suficiente, tá?
E assim, só deixando claro, os
antioxidantes vão ajudar a reduzir
estresse oxidativo, vão ajudar ao fígado
trabalhar para fazer a fase um e fase
dois do detox, mas eles não vão
conseguir sozinhos eliminar o metal do
seu organismo, tá?
E assim, o que que eu recomendo? Faça a
remoção segura dos amálgamas com um
dentista que tenha o treinamento
e ele vai te passar uma aquelação
associado
à remoção do amalgma.
Aí você pode estar usando, né, nesse
período de remoção, gluta selênio,
clorela. Tá bom?
Essa é a última. Não tem mais perguntas
aqui. Eu tenho 76 anos, estou com
doência nos pés e pernas. A
endocrinologista pediu ressonância da
coluna lombar. Seite tarde paraestesia.
Desmarquei o exame porque tive medo do
resultado. Fiz anteriormente
eletroneiografia.
sugerido por neurologista que disse nada
a fazer se não tiver dor.
O exame sugeriu comprometimento
preganglional. Estou apavorada. Esse
quadro tem cura ou tratamento
satisfatório?
Obrigada, Vilma.
Bem, Vilma, eu entendo perfeitamente seu
medo, mas vamos ser direto isso aqui,
né? Esse achado de comprometimento
preganglionar na eletroneurobiografia.
justifica, né, a necessidade de
ressonância
para investigar origem, né, se é uma
herne de disco, se alguma outra coisa tá
comprimindo o nervo, estenose, por
exemplo, que é estreitamento,
o diagnóstico é muito importante para
você saber qual é o tratamento que você
vai fazer.
A boa notícia é que para estes endosos
tem excelente resposta
ao uso de
micronutrientes, né? Vitamina complexo
B, magnésio,
potássio, zinco.
Importante ter uma dieta
antiinflamatória,
entrar com ômega-3 aí para ajudar na
baia neural, né?
falipôico,
controle do açúcar, se tiver
pré-diabetes, né?
Faz da ressonância, não deixa o medo te
atrapalhar nesse sentido. É muito
importante ter o diagnóstico definitivo
e a partir desse diagnóstico você vai
saber melhor qual vai ser o tratamento.
Existe sim vários casos de reversão de
sintomas similares com suplementação
adequada.
mudanças nutricionais e fisioterapia
adequada, tá bom? Então não desista, não
deixe o medo tomar conta de você.
Bem, vamos pro próximo. Aqui tem umas
perguntas que acho que foram durante a
live que foram colocando. Se eu comprar
leite de vaca sem saber se é de pasto ou
grãos, alimentação
e mesmo que seja pasto, mas o capim tem
agrotóxico, o processo para fazer
manteiga guil limpa e purifica. Não, não
dá para confiar na clarificação da
manteiga aqui para tirar o grotóxico,
tá?
Me indique vídeo de da maneira correta e
segura, higiênica, de fazer dieta
cetogênica. Tem tem playlist lá no canal
só para falar disso daí que a dieta
Cetoflex.
É que vocês não pesquisam, pessoal.
Vocês acho engraçado. Mas vamos lá.
Deixa eu entrar no meu YouTube aqui.
É só olhar lá, tem as playlists.
Vou entrar no meu canal aqui. Eu vou
pegar a playlist.
conteúdo playlists.
Vou colocar aqui que é flex
não, deixa eu ver. Cetogênico
aqui. Data lowcab cetogênica.
Ã pã
gerar link compartilhável. Eu vou
colocar o link aqui, ó, e vou colocar o
link também no
grupo, tá bom?
Colocar agora aqui,
ó, playlist
dieta
cetogênica
petoflex.
Pronto,
vamos continuar aqui.
Tá bom, Ton Renato, já coloquei o link
lá da playlist
e você pode pesquisar no canal.
Confiando em Deus e meus pais, vamos nos
consultar com o senhor. No entanto,
sempre quando quero alguma informação,
não consigo falar com a atendente humana
pelos números disponibilizados. Por que
não?
Hoje a vaga para que data poderia me
dizer geralmente espera-se mais de um
mês. Não, geralmente uma semana consegue
consulta mais ou menos entre uma e três
semanas.
Não tem o nome da pessoa aqui, tá? Eu
não sei que número tem o número, tá? Que
é atendimento por IA e tem o número da
secretária, tá? Eu vou colocar no grupo
aqui o o no grupo e na
e também aqui no
na live o número tá,
ó. Vou postar o comentário aqui
e vou
mostrar aqui na tela. Tá aí o número,
tá? Esse é o número que você fala direto
com a secretária.
Não sei se você usou o outro número, mas
o outro número também ele encaminha.
Eu pensei que você tinha visto,
desculpe, aqui, uma psiquiatra, Dra.
Bárbara Wermer.
elogia muito a dieta cetogênica. Cita o
trabalho do Dr. Chris Palmer nos Estados
Unidos que alega que dieta cetogênica
cura esquizofrenia. Não, curar eu acho
demais, mas ajuda muito, né? Achei essa
afirmação muito ousada. Sim, é muito
ousada. Ele alega cinco estudos
randomizados. Poderia, por favor,
analisar e semana que vem ou agora mesmo
se puder ver se isso pode ser verdade?
Não. Dieta citogênica é muito boa, tá?
Que é to flex, tá?
Ah, mas é link de Instagram. Nem gosto
do Instagram. Vamos lá,
vamos abrir esse link aqui,
tá?
Esse é o Dr. Cris Palman, psiquiatra de
Harvard, os pioneiros da psiquiatria
metabólica. Em 2016, um de seus
pacientes com diagnóstico de transtorno
esquisoetivo
vinha sofrendo com ganho de peso. Sugeri
a dieta cetogênica.
Um caso ou outro eu acredito que a dieta
citogênica pode curar, mas assim, ser
uma cura consistente de esquizofrenia é
demais, tá?
H, esse caso inesperado foi stopim para
que Cris Palmer mergulhasse uma profunda
investigação científica.
Nasce ali a base da teoria brain energy,
tá? Eu acho que faz muito bem
fazer a dieta cetogênica paraa
esquizofrenia. Agora, se vai curar a
esquizofrenia, acho aí já é demais. Pode
ser que cure 10% das esquizofrenias, tá?
Que esizofrenia é uma doença
multifatorial aí, não é igual para todo
mundo, mas curar assim todo mundo, não
acredito nisso, tá?
Mas é uma dieta muito curativo para
cérebro, sim.
Doutor Alan, você já recomendou
melatonina 3 horas antes de dormir?
No caso do 5 HTP, tomar quantas horas
antes de dormir?
É mesmo mesmo tempo. Eliseu
tomar ATP com cortisol alto, com
inflamações pode prejudicar a saúde?
Não,
não vai prejudicar, tá?
No caso suplemento magnésio, nós temos
que separar o magnésio elementar do não
elementar. Não é separar, é só calcular
quanto de magnésio elementar tem no
suplemento magnésio, tá? Não interá de
separar, é só calcular. Já no caso de um
alimento rico em magnésio, todo magnésio
do alimento elementar,
depende se esse magnésio tá complexado
com quê? Com cloreto, com
o óxido,
se é com proteína, né? Vai depender
muito de cada cada
situação específica, tá?
Mas aí é mais simples você ver em nível
de nutrição quanto de magnésio tem em
média em 100 g daquele alimento lá, tá?
É, aí é simples assim, não precisa ficar
fazendo cálculo de estequiometria, não.
Pode ter arsênio, sim, tá? O arroz ele
acumula arsênio, ele tem essa
característica. Então é possível que o o
arroz integral tenha em C5.
H, por que que dieta canívora? Porque
tem muitos pacientes que tên autoimune e
que é agravado pelos antinutrientes que
t os vegetais. Aí quando faz a dieta
carnívora e tira esses antinutrientes, o
organismo consegue recuperar. É
basicamente essa resposta rápida,
não? Ah, na verdade o LDL pequeno e
denso, que seria a analogia da bola de
good, é o LDL que oxida, tá bom? Não é
que é exatamente a mesma coisa, mas é o
LDL pequeno e denso que vai acabar
oxidando.
Boa noite.
Isso aí, Cleedivan.
Pessoal, quem quiser participar da live
de estudos avançados, foi muito boa a
live. que aconteceu agora no domingo,
nós ficamos quase 2 horas, é só não
cheguei a 2 horas porque tinha pouca
gente na live, tá bom? Mas perguntem no
grupo lá para quem participou da live de
domingo, o que que eles acharam, tá bom?
Que eu acho que vale a pena, se vocês
tiverem interesse.
Que que é ferver a lata, Maria Helena?
Eh,
eu deixei o número aí, ó, tá? É o nome
da secretária. Vou colocar de novo, tá?
Pera aí.
Pronto, tá aí.
Ah, tem que colocar nos dois, né? Pera
aí. Pronto.
Go gozado. Ah, tá certo. Tá bom. Ã,
eu tô de palitó, eu tô de de blazer, né?
Não tô de terno, não. É, realmente eu
tenho usado pouco palitó ultimamente.
Ten muita paciência com palitó não.
H,
tô procurando perguntas aqui, tá?
Doutora Lâ tentou usar em você a veia
bem fermentada com laranja. Eu não
entendi isso aqui não.
Ah, tá. Você tá falando aqui do negócio
da melatonina, né, que orientei da
dobrar dose. Eu não lembro disso, Maria
Helena, sinceramente.
Não me lembro.
M.
Existe algum suplemento para ajudar no
tratamento de espondilo artrite
anquilosântica, né? Não é ancilosante,
quilosante. Comecei com o tratamento com
imunobiológico. Tem um mês. Você pode
tentar o protocolo de vitamina D em
altas doses, tá? Se você tiver disposta
a fazer a dieta específica ou com baixo
cálcio, você pode tentar usar também
deia em altas doses de HA e pode tentar
o LDN, tá bom?
São opções aí para você queira ou você
não queira fazer o tratamento
imunobiológico. Eu te sugiro o seguinte,
já que tá agendado,
aliás, agendado não, você já começou,
né? começou o tratamento faz um mês,
experimenta dois meses. Se não der
certo, aí eu tentaria usar
o os protocolos de vitamina D em altas
doses ou coisas que eu já comentei aqui.
Olha, primeira coisa é respirar fundo,
Sara. fazer uma respiração profunda, 5
segundos de cada movimento respiratório,
isso já geralmente já corta a crise de
ansiedade.
A respiração é muito poderosa para criar
para cortar crise de ansiedade. E a
média longo prazo tomar liteanina, tomar
taurina, tomar glicina, tomar lisina.
São aminoácido calmantes pro cérebro, tá
bom? Tem o fenibut também.
Você
acha que a vieta carnívor melhores
estratégias controle das doenças
autoimunes? Sim, é uma das melhores. Não
necessariamente não é a primeira medida
a ser tomada. Eu tomaria primeiro como
primeira medida uma dieta mais na linha
da
da dieta mediterrânea ou da
dieta
paleolítica antes de tentar a carnívora,
tá?
Ou pode ser também a cantoflex seria
muito muito interessante.
Boa noite, Dra. Ana Paula. Sim, ajuda na
na compulção alimentar. Bem lembrado.
Ah,
Dr. Alan, por favor, põe a Iá para
trabalhar. É porque dá trabalho, gente.
Eu fiz isso daí e ninguém de vocês quis
assumir para mim isso daí, né? Vocês são
também brincadeira, viu?
fazendo a transcrição das lives de 2025
para achar umas respostas muito rápido.
Foi que tomar tempo mesmo com I tomar
tempo isso aí, Maria Helena, entendeu?
Quanto a nepulasia renal não foi
operada, está em observação vigilância
ativa em função da idade.
Tá, tem a cretinina já alterada aqui.
Pode tentar visvo para ela, viu? Anal.
Errei. Era manteiga. Gui para fazer
manteiga. Confundi. Botei cetogênica.
Não sei se eu entendi isso aqui.
Tem. Tem sim. Você pode usar o pé, o
palmito é llamina 500 mg duas vezes ao
dia. Curcumina de autoabs al
autoabsorção, tipo cocuí, 100 mg duas
vezes ao dia. Se for cocuminascência de
alta absorção, 500 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Bzuel serrata 200 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Esses ajudariam na nevralgia. Poderia
também tá tentando usar, tentando não,
alfalipo seria muito bom para isso
também. Faleip porco 200 mg duas vezes
ao dia. Tá bom?
Ó, para quem quer saber o telefone do
consultório de novo aí na tela.
Isso aqui é a playlist que eu tinha
falado que o Renato perguntou.
Dra. A Paula tá fazendo aqui uma
observação. A sua formação com Dr. Deo
já lhe mostrou que uma neuroinflamação
devido à dietas erradas e a gênese mais
importante na área mental, seja no TEA,
TDAH, demência. Portanto, isso pode ser
estendido para outra. Sim, pode ser. Tem
razão.
Ansiedade, depressão, mas como sempre
nunca somente um pilar. Sim, vários.
Sim, concordo totalmente,
Credivan, possível é improvável,
bem improvável, tá? Se você quer ganhar
massa muscular significativa, vai ser
bem difícil fazer só uma refeição por
dia.
Ah, deixa eu ver se atualizou aqui. Tem
mais uma pergunta aqui que apareceu.
Pronto. Quem se consulta com você tem
direito ao quê?
Consulta e revisão.
Geralmente a gente tem dois sistemas. o
sistema convencional, que é a consulta e
um retorno de 1 hora depois de 1 a 2
meses, mas a maioria hoje tem feito o
retorno seriado semanal que substitui o
retorno de 1 hora, tá? Então é uma
consulta e oito semanas de
acompanhamento pelo WhatsApp.
Tirei a sua dúvida?
Essa é a última pergunta que tinha no
questionário, porque esse software que
eu criei aqui, ele atualiza, tá? Se
tiver entrando pergunta nova, ele
atualiza.
Ã P.
Dout. Alan, existe algum suplemento para
artrose das mãos? Sim. MSM, metilso
sulfonil metano, ácido hialurônico,
o C2, o colágenalizado tipo do próprio
cocumina que eu falei, o próprio PE que
eu falei, tá?
Sendo online. Que que é sendo online?
da pergunta do formulário.
Já olhei aqui, não tem mais não. Acabou
as perguntas do formulário.
Beleza. Vou até fazer um double check
aqui, ó.
Vai até o número 23. Então são 22. É,
não, acabou mesmo, tá? As perguntas.
Bem, pessoal, estamos atingindo uma uma
hora de live. Eu acho que eu já tirei as
dúvidas todas de vocês, tá? Eu vou fazer
o seguinte, eu vou dar uma chegada no
banheiro agora e aí quando eu voltar eu
vejo se tem mais algumas perguntas e a
gente encerra, tá bom?
Ah, deixa eu só
fazer uma coisinha antes aqui de ir no
banheiro.
Bem, vamos lá.
Ah,
que que tem a consulta online, Antônio
Renatos? Não entendi a pergunta.
Se eu faço consulta online, faço sim.
Tá.
Posso usar o DMSO para Busit? Tem
direito, sim. Pode pode usar tanto
aplicando diretamente sobre
articulação inflamada, né, e fazendo
massagem, pode associar o dementsor com
várias outras substâncias analgésicas
para uso local tópico. E com muito
cuidado é possível até fazer uso oral,
apesar de não ser um uso oficial, tá?
Sim, a online tem a mesma situação, não
muda nada, tá?
Sim. Eh, aí você tem que pedir uma
análise para quem tiver vendendo,
tá, de contaminantes desse DMSO, tá?
Seria a melhor maneira de você ver um
fornecedor idôneo.
Exame. Sim. Você pode pedir pra
secretária, quando você for agendar a
consulta, pede pra secretária te mandar
o pedido de exames para você adiantando,
tá bom?
É perfeitamente possível isso.
Ué,
não tem mais pergunta tua aqui não,
Antônio Renato, cadê?
Seria essa aqui?
Essa aqui que da Essa aqui eu vi, mas eu
preciso ver com mais calma. Tá, eu já
respondi essa pergunta aqui da, eu não
acredito que a diacetogênica cure a
esquizofrenia, pelo menos a maioria dos
casos. Vai ajudar muito, mas não vai
curar. É essa que você que tu queria?
Ah, não, tu colocou aqui, ó, dieta
cetogênica é muito boa, mas se uma
pessoa tiver câncer sem saber ou celular
celular
cancerígenas, pode estar se alimentando
o câncer com a cetose?
Não. A questão é o seguinte, a maioria
dos câncer eles é glicogênico, tá?
Aliás, é glicolítico. Ele ele se
alimenta de glicose
ou até mesmo de glutamina.
Só que existe a flexibilidade metabólica
do tumor também. E como eu falei, 20%
dos tumores podem usar ácidos grassos,
tá? A dieta cetogênica não vai alimentar
o tumor. O que pode acontecer que a
dieta cetogênica pare de ser eficaz pro
tumor, tá bom? Deu para entender a
diferença?
Tá. Respondi a sua pergunta, Antônio.
Dr. Lug para o valístico, como utilizar
primeiro set fix
e do rachimoto, né? Veja seus anticorpos
e se você não tem inflamação da
tireoide, aí você poderia estar
utilizando duas gotas por dia de logol,
tá bom? conjunto com selên
viver 100 anos consumindo os mesmos
alimentos. Preciso licença para provar
algo contrário.
Isso é para mim ou só tava conversando
com outra pessoa aqui. Clevan,
doutor, você viu um estudo publicado no
site do Mercola sobre o impacto da
cetogênica no fígado? Não, não vi. Vou
dar uma olhada. É o parece que o mec tá
bem contra agora a dieta cetogênica, mas
tem dietas e dietas cetogênicas, tá
pessoal? Depende muito como é feita.
Beleza? Podemos colocar. Só que tem o
detalhe o seguinte, vocês optaram que as
lives era para tirar dúvida, certo?
Então eu vou fazer sim a análise desse
impacto da dieta cetogênica, só que eu
vou fazer naquelas lives a cada duas
semanas do grupo avançado, não vou fazer
aqui não, tá?
Você acha para você? Não entendi.
Sim, respondi, né? Obrigado. Obrigado,
D. Renato.
Eu não tô entendendo o que que tá
querendo dizer aqui para você, doutor.
Tá. Bom descanso para você também, Maria
Helena.
Tá bom. Então, aí nós vamos deixar essas
discussões profundas de artigos para a o
grupo
de estudos avançados. Eu fiquei
praticamente 2 horas na live agora de
domingo, tá? Perguntem para quem
participou, o que que achou da live, tá
bom? Aí a gente pode fazer essa análise
aprofundada aí desse artigo do Mercola.
Eu vou até localizar esse artigo agora.
Pessoal, muito obrigado aí pela
participação.
Nós nos vemos então na semana que vem.
Abraço no coração de vocês aí. Abraço,
um beijo no coração. Vou achar o artigo
do Becola aqui para eu poder fazer esse
levantamento. Ciao. Ciao.